I guess there are at least two aspects
to his situation that have caught the
public's attention one is the whole
issue of whether or not someone of his
prominence was given special attention
in terms of access to a liver and the
other has to do with the indication for
his liver transplantation now with
regard to the former let me say that the
distribution system for solid organs has
advanced particularly livers has
advanced tremendously to a more fair
more fair and equitable system with the
evolution of the Mel system of scoring
so the the the the system allocates
organs based on generally on the
severity of the liver disease it's
organized on a regional basis some areas
of the country have better access to
more livers than other areas of the
country now according to the press he
got his transplant in Tennessee and
based on what I know the availabilities
of livers in Tennessee might be better
than say on either coast if that was the
case there's nothing inappropriate about
that there's no there's not there's
nothing
he wasn't gaming a system in any way
many people will will it will have
themselves listed in more than one
region in an attempt to get access to a
liver so III think that that that's how
I would comment on that aspect of with
regard to the indication yeah you know
again it's not clear what is original to
yet a pancreatic tumor there there there
there are a number of different kinds of
pancreatic tumors the most common is
what's called an adenocarcinoma of the
pancreas and this is a devastating
disease with a very poor prognosis that
has a 5-year survival in general
less than 5% it would be highly highly
unlikely that that was the kind of tumor
that he had or that anyone would
consider a liver transplant for that
kind of a tumor when the tumor went to
the liver so the likelihood is that he
had some type of a neuroendocrine tumor
which are generally slow growing tumors
and the likelihood is from what I've
read that that the tumor was resected
but probably had metastasized to the
liver and that that was the indication
for a liver transplant and and in fact
at many centers a transplant for a
neuroendocrine tumor that's metastasized
to the lizard liver is considered
appropriate